heißt es einfach also es ist
grundverschieden jetzt die
spielerfahrung vorher was aufgabe so
dass man immer stress hatte mit teams
mittlerweile gibt es einfach keine teams
mehr
servus es geht sondern will kommt zu
einer 95 24 es geht direkt losspielen ja
auf murmeltier games und die runde
startet instant karma das war eine ganz
gute erste kiste kann man somit nehmen
heute gibt es zwei oder sogar drei
wichtige dinge zu besprechen
und zwar als allererstes wollte ich euch
mal so kurz vorstellen was ich so an
neuem spielzeug bekommen habt das heißt
mein neues equipment mal kurz vorstellen
so was alles neu ist hier in meinem
aufnahme zimmer vielleicht post ich nach
ein foto auf instagram da können alle
die mir auf instagram folgen da noch
zuschauen instagram escape weil die mich
nicht kennen da gerne mal vorbeischauen
da sind wir auch schon echt viel ich
glaube schon
schon 1300 leute oder so also richtig
krass feierlich extrem das ist ja schon
so viele leute da zusammengefunden haben
und wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an also
als allererstes zu nennen ist wohl die
ja die softbox ihr märz wahrscheinlich
das bild ist 1000 mal heller ich finds
richtig geil
wir haben richtig richtig helles geiles
bild wird mit dieser softbox und ja ich
feiere ist einfach alle die die face com
aufnahmen sind 1000 mal geil ruft
service bietet oft ja nicht weg naja
egal
die face kamera aufnahmen sind 1000 war
geil finde ich zumindest so der will es
jetzt auch eingreifen dahinter musste
kurz mal gucken wie wir den gut
erwischen ich habe dazu noch eine neue
tastatur und einen neuen bildschirm
besteht also wie gesagt falls ihr das
mal sehen wollt schreibt sie noch einmal
in die kommentare und dann mache ich da
auf instagram bild ich kann euch meinen
instagram bekommt auch mal verlinken so
gut wie das geht gut sagt der mann
hinter dem anderen mal aufpassen denn es
sei eine ungünstige lage erwischt sagt
erstmals kunden sehr voll da geht
einfach da ein anderer läufer unter
alles klar
warum auch nicht so willst du jetzt hier
ja also wie gesagt softbox
bildschirmtastatur sind neu der pc
natürlich auch und ich werde mir
demnächst noch einen neuen pc bestellen
sagte er sei auch sehr gut
alles klar und jetzt kommt der ortler in
südtirol ist die diamanten ich glaube
nicht
ja ok screen komische machen
na gut ich meine leute gerne ich freue
mich immer wenn leute sagen hey was geht
ab ist er juristisch dann will ich auch
nicht den screamer wären kein ding und
ja wie gesagt es gibt einiges an neuem
equipment aber ich werde wahrscheinlich
noch eine neue pc bestellen und zwar in
der letzten folge gesagt so ein von
einer firma die ich jetzt noch nicht
nennen vielleicht mache mit dem
telefonieren vielleicht haben die ja
irgendwie lust auf so eine kooperation
oder so müssen wir mal schauen und dann
kann ich mal mit mehr dazu erzählen auf
jeden fall ist es ein krasser rechner
er ist ziemlich gut und auch echt nicht
teuer für den bald für das wasser kann
vielleicht schaue ich mal gehen wird
sich noch zeigen
auf jeden fall bin ich jetzt der
komplett neu eingedeckt ich nehme immer
noch ein zwei laptops auf das hat ja
zwei laptops an zwei pcs hier unten
rechts
die facetime über den laptop und auf
meinem desktop apps audacity und was
noch raps oder city und jamaika also
minecraft das spiel hat läuft da so und
wir haben es leider nicht genug zeug
führen die affären die er wollte mir
noch gucken ob wir noch zusammenkriegen
auf jeden fall gibt das zweite thema
leute es gibt einfach in zwei williams
keine teams mehr das ist so geil ich
feiere das so hart
ist einfach kanal ich finde statt das
spielerlebnis komplett verändert es gibt
einfach gar keine teams mehr so der
wahrscheinlich in seinen sms schicken
die geplante wahrscheinlich schon und ja
es ist einfach alles grundverschieden
jetzt die spielerfahrung vorher was
aufkommen so dass man immer stress hatte
mit teams mittlerweile gibt es einfach
keine teams mehr das ist ultra geil und
ich finde aber natürlich kann was er
will
also ich muss wirklich sagen hut ab das
war echt gut und die dritte sache wie
ihr euch auch sagen wollte seit wieder
fleißig bitte und schreibt mal in die
kommentare was ich dazu an genesis
online wie billig wie billig moment mal
das ist da noch ein dritter wo es der
dritte em macht einfach jedesmal die g2
auf 1 gg okay man ist das stressig sg
zweidorf ein naja ok können sie ja
machen wie die lust haben nur fünf
minuten haben wir darum kümmert jeden
fall noch eine runden dranhängen so der
sind wieder ich habe mich einfach jetzt
noch kein kürzel games sondern ein
anderes mal wieder kontrolliert
parallels kann ich überhaupt gar keine
ahnung was haben sie von anfangs gut
bekommen
holder liebald für der waagerecht der
kann sich durchaus sehen lassen kann man
ja mal kurz rein
ja das ist schon ein bisschen gar keine
verbesserung mehr sagt sagt sagt das ist
echt nice so jetzt können wir auf jeden
fall eine schöne runde spielen denke ich
mal wenn wir jetzt ein bisschen geschick
vielen nicht in größere schwierigkeiten
kommen
sagte wollte ich jetzt nicht drücken
sagten am erwischt dann doch die pfeile
die ja gerade verschossen hat ihr so
online das hier mal kurz an
sagt dir auch noch erwischt sehr gut ist
muss aufpassen dass hier keiner hier
drin überrascht dass dinge ausziehen und
ihren kompass sehr nice alles klar
chillige ohne bisher würde ich sagen die
kampfsituation ganz klassisch wieder
etwas verschwiegen von meiner seite
es soll dafür habe ich denke mal da geht
in ordnung und ja ich wollte mal das
dritte thema betonen und zwar dass ich
doch bitte dass ihr bitte möglichst
fleißig das schmeiße hat auf den boden
dass ihr möglichst fleißig eure
challenges wie denn die kommentare
schreibt damit wir nicht machen können
so wie ihr sie euch vorstellt das wort
das wir betonen kollege das bringt nur
relativ wenig hier hat er den hit
gesehen also was war das für ein hit im
letzten moment paulina paulina prima was
machst du nur was machst du jetzt senkt
sich mit dem ns austricksen
ja da haben wir sehr gut sehr gut sehr
gut
goarshausen reiste kombi aber jetzt wäre
richtig toll ein und wir haben sechs
eisen das gibt es nicht sechs
motherfucker reisen
das hat ja noch nie alto oder gegners
hat uns jetzt nicht auf was wir zu recht
eine solide runde bisher hingelegt jetzt
aufpassen dass nicht viel selbst
vermiesen
der gerade eben wollt uns ein bisschen
abstauben auffahrt auftrag auftrag
auffahrt lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf
lauf lauf lauf lauf lauf einfach lauf
lauf lauf
ich kann es nicht oft genug betont man
ich hab kein bock dass die runde
verpackt wird so erzählt den fight gegen
den tüten olaf jacobi aber schon mit dem
bogen bisschen enttäuschend alles klar
darauf hat er keine lust aber ich hab
das darauf dass ich dich töten
wir müssen wir müssen jetzt kämpfen wir
müssen kämpfen
okay er macht ein platz frei wird auf
den fall fest platzieren
ja das tut es auch ein spaßvogel die
ganze decke läuft leute darauf habe ich
keine lust man was denkst du denn hier
blockiere blog da sie ist ein echtes
west wissen die westliche die ganze
ganze weglaufen warum ich verstehe es
nicht
wie gesagt es ist nicht fucking weg
lauft games den befehl komplett die
worte sind sind die leute irgendwie
halten sie sich für crysis killer dafür
dass sie weglaufen ich meine laune hat
kann er nicht sein dürfen hier hinterher
ja aber klar der festplatten aber noch
aus
das habe ja gerade so was von instant
gelöscht alter krass das war echt
schlecht dass mir gut gefallen nach
knapp knapp verfehlt den kollegen egal
dem lande bleiben dran und es geht dann
auch demnächst ins match da kann man
sowieso nicht immer ewig weglaufen weil
sie seit ich viel steht diese leute
nicht er denkt sich auch habe ich hoffe
so welt bis ich eine serbische ja da
kommt jetzt andere ja es hat jetzt davon
hätte mal lieber angeblich gemacht wenn
wir das nicht passiert so jetzt passiert
eben so laufen folgen
nein ich bin so einen lappen
nein nein ob ich wieder selbst
eingesteckt schade da bist echt selbst
verdorben
naja leute wenn euch die ohne gefallen
hat dann könnt ihr gerne einen daumen da
lassen schreibt eure handicaps in die
kommentare
weder handicaps machen können oder
nutzen will ich sage wir sind zwar nicht
wieder machen